non moi j'aimerais qu'on vient dans
l'histoire de tommy pour vous tommy a
menti sur toute la ligne
oui 2 avec 2 à z il n'a jamais été
violente et non non mais je suis
persuadé que mes collègues mais non mais
attendez mais ça on voulait ses preuves
moi je n'ai pas confiance dans les plus
gros boum avec aucune preuve des mains
pour quels sont les auteurs vous êtes
juste un menteur un menteur et cc vous
vous avez occupé mais je viens de votre
vue ça vous poursuit droits ont été
violés sûr j'étais comme ça monsieur moi
pardon peut voir naître votre syndicat
du front national
vous n'êtes pas d'audience nationale
vous damien rieu à toi vous dites qu'il
faut expulser les étrangers boudent 28
sur 28 sur 20 c'est vous parler d'islam
au gauchisme et compagnie ça va deux
secondes un moment donné aux écolos vous
et moi j'ai utilisé le mot mais est-ce
que vous pouvez répondre si linda cup
est une arabe de service s'il vous plaît
jérémy reçu très mal est-ce que linda
qui bob et une arabe de service vous
pouvez répondre c'est pas le procès de
la boire c'est bien de voir nicolas
pères n'aurait volo moi j'ai une
question à vous poser
il vient sur les plateaux de manière
anonyme il a reconnu hier qu'il était
avec un véhicule volé d'élite fille
macha expliquez moi en 30 secondes
la stratégie de ce garçon pourquoi il
fait ça vous pouvez expliquer alors je
vous pose une autre question
expliquez-moi la stratégie de mes
collègues qui vont être dans une fouille
ont retiré leurs gants et qui vont lui
mettre un doigt dans le cul et cette
dispute humour un chardon ça existe et
vous les voyez aussi madame mais les
deux côtés célèbres ou alors ça vous
avez pas d'arguments j'en ai pas donc à
50 50
vous posez une question sans vous me
répondez avec les éléments que vous avez
est ce que vous avez déjà des éléments
de l'enquète qui prouve que tommy aurait
maintenu d'après vous non non vous n'en
avez pas non j'ai travaillé sur les
vidéos qu'ils ont fait
je sais qu'il est un peu gêné il a fait
plusieurs interviews et donc du coup
elles correspondent pas donc allez sur
le stylo site street ce trio comme ça
donc vous avez des trucs bio gissinger
vos notes
voilà l'ouémé s'arrête parce qu'on parle
de casiers de tommy on veut parler du
gaz et du commissariat du vième
arrondissement qui est tristement
célèbre il ya un journaliste qui a
infiltré le commissariat pendant deux
ans et qui racontent ce que tommy en
train de dire c'est à dire des violences
c'est à dire des violences racistes
le lycéen de bergson qui s'est fait
frapper et un policier ont été condamnés
du commissaire admettons il ya des
mauvais chez steria du 19e
arrondissement il est connu sur un
commissariat violent un commissariat où
il y avait des éléments des gens qui
sont racistes et vous venez nous dire
circulez ya rien à voir comme pour la